seigneur anos je suis désolé j'encourage
ou à me débarrasser de cet usurpateur
d'ailleurs au sel
très bien je dois me occuperait moinet
[Musique]
je vous la vous j'ai des regrets
je regrette de ne pas m'être mis au
marvel avant j'avais des préjugés sur
les films et au final je suis
aujourd'hui un énorme fan et maintenant
qu'ils ne finissent ivoire a été
annoncée je suis comme un dingue je veux
découvrir thanos je veux voir sa
puissance
parlons donc aujourd'hui de trois
théories qui pourrait potentiellement
arriver dans ce prochain opus jeu sera
accompagné de mon célèbre allié à et
recettes pour théoriser sur le combat
ultime
nous reparlerons de sa chaîne en fin de
vidéo bref amenant les théories bien le
bonjour voyageurs
pour cette première théorie commençons
plutôt tranquillement avec une petite
suppositions dans thor ragnarok nous
avons le plaisir de voir le docteur
strange ou un rôle dedans dernier
intercepte or afin de lui dire que lui
et son frère ne sont pas les bienvenus à
new york
il aidera donc tort à retrouver dans sa
quête son père exilé pour qu'il puisse
repartir au plus vite
cependant ou théâtre hélas la soeur
cachée de thor apparaissent suite à la
mort d'odin et détruit mjöllnir le
marteau de thor le dieu du tonnerre se
retrouvent donc maintenant sans son
marteau son arme de prédilection
maintenant si on s'intéresse à une
infiniti war nous savons que thor sera
sans son marteau et sera donc fort
probable que ce dernier combattent avec
une gare neuron excusez-le pour la
prononciation
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a sous-entendu
chris hemsworth l'acteur de thor
lui-même yarn bjorn était une hache de
guerre forgée par les nains port
l'utilisa pendant un très long moment
avant d'obtenir mjolnir hell est
indestructible le plus pointu que
n'importe quelle arme et peut quasiment
tout couper alliés aux pouvoirs de thor
elle peut faire de sévères ravages mais
les réalisateurs ont aussi laissé
sous-entendre que nous reverrions
potentiellement mjolnir comment cela se
pourrait-il tantôt ragnarok odin semble
essayer d' éduquer son fils à ce qu'il
use de son réel pouvoir qu'il n'est pas
le dieu des marteaux mais du tonnerre et
bizarrement docteur strange sait
exactement où se trouve odin il est fort
probable que ces deux derniers et
peut-être mijoter quelque chose ensemble
pour donner une leçon à tort pourquoi
pas odin souhaitait réellement que son
fils arrête de ne jurer que par son
marteau et donc il use de son réel
pouvoir pour avoir peut-être la chance
de vaincre et là qui effrayait taudin
quant à l'avenir das garde une leçon
aurait pu donc être donné à tort par le
biais dodin mais aussi du docteur
strange et bien évidemment si mjolnir
réapparaît ce serait donc grâce au
docteur ce dernier pourrait user du
pouvoir de l'oeil d'agde à moto pour
justement reformé mjolnir à partir d'un
débris reprises sur le lieu d'exil là où
thor perdu son marteau d'ailleurs
maintenant que tu auras compris la leçon
ici utilisé son véritable pouvoir
imaginez s'il venait à récupérer son
marteau et serait la parfaite
description de son titre
le dieu du tonnerre
alliant la maîtrise de son arme à son
réel pouvoir tort serait quasiment
invincible dans tous les cas a strange
jouera certainement un rôle plutôt
majeur dans le prochain opus
possédant une carte l'infinité même si
nous savons qu il la perdra face à
l'ordre noir
dites nous ce que vous en pensez dans
les commentaires
[Musique]
parlons pour continuer de la question
qui fâche et qui va attrister la
majorité d'entre nous thanos et depuis
le début le méchant ultime
le point culminant du mc eu et après
tant d'années le combat final est enfin
annoncée cependant je suis désolé mais
marvel restent pour la plupart du temps
assez bisounours
les héros gagne toujours et tout finit
bien de plus nos chers avengers vont
tout de même affronter thanos qui est un
éternel en possession du gant de
l'infini et qu'il est quasiment certain
qu'il trouvera les pierres d'infinité
pour moi et j'en parlais justement avec
aero au moins un ou deux avengers vont
mourir d'après ni marvel est obligé de
sacrifier au moins un de ces héros pour
prouver la dangerosité le pouvoir de
thanos qui est loin d'être un ennemi
comme les autres vous allez bien
évidemment me demander mais quel héros
pourrait mourir
c'est la question que nous allons tenter
de répondre ensemble tout d'abord pour
ceux qui ne seraient pas avengers 3 sera
divisé en deux parties un petit peu
comme harry potter 7 et 8 ans film
avengers 4 a été annoncé est à nocé
toujours dedans donc avengers 3 sera la
première partie du combat final il est
alors fort possible que personne ne
meurt dans avengers 3 mais certainement
dans avengers 4 d'ailleurs d'après moi
pour que tanoh ce réellement craint par
les douleurs les avengers il doit
absolument tu es un amateur principal
qui est là depuis le début
du coup en premier lieu dans mes
recherches je suis allé regarder le
casting d'avengers 4 pour voir si un
héros manqueraient à l'appel mais tous
seront là sans exception c'est un héros
de mourir c'est pour une seule et même
raison soit son contrat avec marvel est
bientôt terminée donc par exemple
l'acteur on a tout simplement marre soit
que plus aucun film n'est prévu en sa
compagnie car cela ne fait plus assez
d'argent par exemple et là nous pouvons
pointé du doigt certains acteurs tout
d'abord captain america joué par chris
evans sans parler d'argent ou autre
contrat c'est un héros toujours prêt à
se sacrifier pour les autres et qui
possède beaucoup de mal à retrouver une
certaine joie de vivre suite à son
réveil d'après 70 ans de congélation
de plus le trailer nous le montre en
train de se faire vaincre par thanos
cela reste un trailer mais cela peut
être une piste aussi
continuez et chris evans n'a pas
renouvelé deux contrats avec marvel
après 2020 donc il se peut fortement que
captain america se laisse partir
après tout ils n'étaient pas cette
époque maintenant parlons de tony stark
est oui iron man ne possède plus de
contrat lui aussi après avengers 4 du
moins pour le moment
robert downey junior est maintenant âgé
de 51 ans et tous les films d'iron man
sont sortis depuis quelques années déjà
le personnage d'iron man n'est présent
que pour les avengers ou autre crossover
et il n'a plus rien à prouver
tahouni commence à vieillir et son
personnage aussi il est tout aussi
possible d'autant que captain america qu
iron man ne quitte pour cet ultime
affrontement
enfin d'après moi l'avenger ce qui est
sûr à 100% de mourir n'est autre que
vision ce dernier est en possession
d'une pierre d'infinité qui lui donne un
certain pouvoir
si thanos convoitent les pierres il
devra forcément la lui prendre sur sa
tête et site annonce est réellement
mauvais et surpuissant ce qui est
certain il n'hésitera pas une seule
seconde à le détruire pour la voir il
est vrai que je ne parle pas vraiment
des futurs nouveaux avengers mais bon
spider man est trop récent pour être
tués ainsi que dr strange qui doit jouer
dans doctor strange 2 ou encore les
gardiens la galaxie qui doivent
continuer leur périple principal dans un
troisième opus
ils sont d'ailleurs tous présents dans
le casting bref à vous de nous dire ce
que vous en pensez
alors oui la mort de certains héros
pourrait arriver mais si nous sommes
dans le point culminant l'ultime
affrontement de la série tous les gros
moyens sont c'est arrivé pour ceux qui
ne sauraient pas thanos le grand méchant
de la saga est connu pour être tombé fou
amoureux de la mort auprès de laquelle
il développera ses pouvoirs et ses
envies de conquêtes
maintenant j'aimerais vous faire
réfléchir sur un point je lisais dans
mon trois théories sur doctor strange
christine palmer est l'homologue de clé
à l'amour du docteur strange dans les
films car son personnage est complexe
pas adapté à l'histoire créés etc etc et
fils ne retranscrivent pas totalement
voir peu à certains moments les comics
elles servent juste de base
d'inspiration
maintenant si nous revenons à ce que
nous disions tanoh cet amoureux de la
mort cependant je vois mal un personnage
désignée comme la mort à paraître dans
les films trop abstrait trop compliqué
trop surnaturel vision est déjà pas mal
réduit je trouve dans les films alors
imaginez un personnage comme celle de la
mort mieux bref si je vous dis tout ça
ce n'est pas pour rien car je pense
qu'un homologue de la mort est justement
présent dans les films est là et là
était la déesse de la mort et fut
vaincue sur asgard par le démon enflammé
ramené par thor et j'insiste sur le
vaincu je vais appliquer la règle
logique est connu du je ne vois pas le
corps il n'y a donc pas de morts nous
voyons juste et là se faire soit disant
écrasé mais je suis certain qu'elle
n'est pas morte c'est trop facile
surtout que du coup elle assemble être
l'homologue de la mort elle a d'ailleurs
énormément de vécu ce qui expliquerait
qu'elle est connue la noce qui
d'ailleurs a soif de conquête et de
destructions ne serait ce pas un petit
peu comme hélas en compagnie dodin avant
son exil
thanos aurait donc pu très bien tombé
amoureux d'elle ces dernières pourraient
donc le rejoindre pour l'ultime
affrontement imaginer tous les héros
réuni façade deux ennemis incroyablement
puissant thanos et elles voire plus
encore
j'espère que ces trois théories vous
auront plus je deviens réel fan des
films du mc eu et je suis sincèrement
admirative de l'intelligence de la saga
avenger
je suis impatient de voir l'opus 3 et si
je le pouvais j'irais le voir avec mon
ami aéronefs
d'ailleurs en parlant des héros il me
semble que ce dernier a sorti exactement
au même moment une vidéo théorie sur
avengers 3 lui aussi je vous conseille
de foncer aller la voir
c'est un réel honneur d'avoir été invité
sur ce trois théories
depuis le temps qu'on a envie de faire
un truc ensemble avec ce cher hard rock
ça fait vraiment plaisir comme précisé
j'ai également sorti une vidéo consacrée
infiniti war et de mon côté j'ai bien
entendu d'autres théories à vous
proposer
n'oubliez pas le like et l'abonnement
aide énormément c'est une manière de
récompenser le travail fourni et de
montrer votre soutien surtout cargo rock
il le mérite amplement
[Musique]
n'oubliez pas de me suivre sur twitter
c'est très important
cet argot rock et que le liner soit avec
vous
[Musique]